bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien de
l'intelligence économique l'émission
consacrée aux coulisses de la
mondialisation
protéger les savoir faire des artisans
et bien c'est le projet de la commission
européenne qui veut étendre le label ige
pour indication géographique aux
produits manufacturiers bruxelles prend
ainsi exemple sur la france qui protège
déjà ses artisans pour en parler je
reçois rémy dauphin directeur de
l'association mais dean grand test qui
défend la propriété intellectuelle
266 professionnels de l'ameublement
installés dans la région du grand est
bon jour et me dauphin dont j'aurai un
mot sur votre association alors médine
gantès est un groupement d'entreprises
qui rassemble 166 entreprises comme vous
l'avez et on a trois missions on a une
mission de représentation de ces
entreprises là auprès des autorités
publiques une deuxième on accompagne le
développement économique de ces
entreprises donc sur beaucoup de
domaines donc la rh le juridique
l'environnemental brady et troisième
domaine c'est la promotion promotion des
métiers des savoir faire et donc c'est
là dans ce domaine là qu'on trouve
l'indication géographique alors c'est
quoi une indication géographique alors
une indication géographique c'est un
label label d'état oui qui garantit un
lien entre un produit et son territoire
donc c'est un label national pour
l'instant c'est tout à fait vrai pour le
moment c'est nationale ça existe déjà au
niveau européen pour les produits
alliant alimentaire mais pour les
produits manufacturés ça n'existe qu'au
niveau national comme on ne décroche en
prouvant que son produit vient bien de
la région c'est ça ouais tout à fait et
est-ce que c'est avant tout une
assurance contre la contrefaçon c'est ça
oui tout à fait c'est vraiment une
assurance contre la contrefaçon nous
nous défendons l'indication géographique
siège d'apple donc ce mobilier mais il
ya d'autres indications géographiques en
france tels que la porcelaine de limoges
les charentaises mais ça c'est ce sont
des produits qui sont très souvent copié
aux pieds dans l'eau et alors je la
france a été pionnière non dès 2014
alors l avesnois oui tout à fait c'est
la loi sur la consommation ou loi dite
hamon qui qui a été en effet pionnière
en europe parce qu'on a une protection
qui est vraiment très forte très
contrôlé c'est une protection qui est
contrôlé par par l'inpi au niveau
national alors d'une piste l'institut
national la propriété exactement c'est
ça c'est là qu'on dépose quale les
dessins les toute la grossesse et c'est
exactement d'accord pourquoi vous avez
décidé dans le grand est de le faire de
faire cette action auprès des
entreprises alors pour nous c'est très
simple l'objectif n'était pas de lutter
contre la contrefaçon parce que nos
produits sont assez peu connu l'idée
pour nous c'était de faire connaître un
savoir-faire de le défendre sur sur
notre territoire mais aussi au delà des
frontières de la france est également de
permettre de valoriser auprès du grand
public une histoire un patrimoine qui
est lié à un territoire donc vous le
disiez le premier à avoir décroché le
label ige indication géographique dans
l'artisanat c'est le siège de l'i-phone
sequans a fait alors le siège de l'i
phone c'est un savoir faire qui en ont
tous moyen-âge ah oui qui se trouvent
dans grand test à coeuve et région
spécifique tout à fait vraiment très
spécifique c'est un savoir faire qui est
répandu sur à peu près 50 kilomètres
carrés
et qui remonte au moyen âge c'était une
terre qui était qui faisait l'objet de
beaucoup de conflits entre le duché de
lorraine well duché de bourgogne et donc
vous aviez des châteaux des monastères
qui a été là et il y avait une ressource
locale qui était le bois le bois de
hêtre faut savoir que le être signe des
ressources qui est la plus utilisée dans
la fabrication de meubles mais donc les
personnes qui habitait là se sont mises
à fabriquer des meubles pour ses
châteaux et ses monastères concrètement
donc ils ont le label depuis de 2016
concrètement vous avez un bilan vous
avez préservé gagner des emplois qu
est-ce qui sera on a préservé un peu
près 150 emplois sur le secteur ça peut
paraître petit comme ça mais c'est très
important pour des territoires ruraux
emplois directs et 100 pas dire qu'on ne
peut pas dire indirectement on peut
alors indirectement il ya derrière des
activités de tourisme
il ya des activités de promotion liés au
territoire sur sur les questions de
formation faut savoir que nous sommes
une indication géographique qui compte
parmi ses entreprises labellisées à un
centre de formation d'accord et ça c'est
important pour nous parce que c'est ça
permet de pérenniser des savoir faire
qui sont en 13 ans et ce trop mais qui
aussi sans capacité de s'adapter aux
modes et aux évolutions de des
consommateurs c'est que l'on a c'est
avant 2016 alors oui il ya certains
métiers qui sont menacés par exemple le
métier de sculpteur c'est un métier et
sculpteurs pour en oeuvre c'est un
métier qui tient un peu en voie de
disparition alors il ya évidemment
d'autres labels en france vous l'avais
dit la personne de limoges des
tapisseries d'aubusson il y aurait 12 12
filières en france pub oui tout à fait
peuvent avoir la lige et oui oui tout à
fait vous travaillez ensemble on
travaille ensemble on est rassemblée au
sein d'une association qui s'appelle la
fia pour association française des
indications géographiques pour les
produits industriels et artisanaux et
donc nous sommes tous regroupés ensemble
pour justement faire des partage de
connaissances parce que rédiger un
cahier des charges c'est pas forcément
évident pour nous le monde il ya des
procédures de contrôle nous sommes
contrôlés tous les ans donc c'est des
contrôles qui sont assez lourds à ces
techniques et donc c'est important aussi
de pouvoir échanger avec d'autres
savoir-faire sur les bonnes pratiques
sur un certain nombre de choses comme ça
mais également pour faire valoir
l'importance de protéger ce savoir faire
à une autre échelle l'échelle de l'union
européenne va rôle qui frappe à votre
porte en ce moment qu'ils aimeraient
bien avoir le label g alors pour pour ce
label là il faut être dans un
territoire bien précis donc c'est un
périmètre spécifique je vous le disais
tout à l'heure c'est 50 kilomètres
carrés autour de l' iphone legrand ne
marche pas généralement en france qui
souhaiteraient avoir ce label j abba
vous avez par exemple le savon de
marseille vous avez les poteries
d'alsace qui ont été toujours fabriqué à
marseille alors justement c'était
voilà il ya exactement une polémique qui
fait les couteaux de laguiole par
exemple il ya s'en prive ouais dans
l'aveyron soulage tout à fait voilà donc
ça c'est voilà c'est des savoir-faire
titi sont alors c'est pas évident parce
que vous avez le village d'à côté ils
tiennent aussi dans le permettre donc
voilà c'est beau aussi beaucoup de
négociations parce que c'est un
patrimoine un patrimoine territorial bon
il ya des enjeux d'emplois au sida enfin
s'intéresse bruxelles allant alors
sintas bruxelles enfin comme vous l'avez
dit
non c'est une blague parce que le
l'union européenne elle s'y intéresse
depuis plusieurs années la seule
difficulté c'est que vous l'avez dit la
france elle a été pionnière avec un
système très très fort très contrôlé
très cadrée alors que lundi voilà treize
ministres et la france
mais mais voilà il ya d'autres pays qui
eux ont un système beaucoup plus de
marque donc un système beaucoup plus
privé que public donc il faut il fallait
pour la commission européenne faire une
synthèse de tous ces systèmes l'avs il
ya même des pays qui n'ont aucun système
de protection de leur savoir faire il
fallait voir donc faire une étude
d'analyste sur ces systèmes là et
ensuite voir comment on peut harmoniser
et ce qu'il faut créer un système qu'on
appelle sui generis tu veux dire créer
proprement à l'union européenne ou
s'inspire d'une agence créer une agence
européenne alors c'est la réflexion ou
pas n'ont alors pas d'âge ans
particulièrement puisqu'il ya déjà un
institut européen de la propriété
intellectuelle donc c'est lui qui sera à
priori d'après la proposition qui est
sorti par la fin que la commission
européenne abe
édité en avril dernier
la commission européenne souhaite se
reposer sur cet institut européen de la
propriété intellectuelle ça peut pas du
protectionnisme non alors non l'idée
pour son
nom alors je rappelle que la devise de
l'union européenne s'est unie dans la
diversité on a une diversité de savoir
faire qui est extraordinaire dans toute
l'union au maine l'idée ce n'est pas de
dire à balsièges de iphone ces scans
mieux ce qu'il ya de plus qualitatif les
sièges italiens sont moins bien c'est
pas du tout ça l'idée c'est de montrer
qu'il ya un lien une histoire un savoir
faire qui est ancré dans son territoire
et les par exemple si je prends un
exemple le verre de murano intéressé par
sony la venise vous pouvez avoir le
cristal de baccarat tient aussi en grand
test eh ben c'est un savoir faire qui
est proche mais il ya des spécificités
il ya des styles différents c'est comme
quand vous achetez une paire de baskets
vous achetez une marque particulière
dans la mare si je puis dire c'est le
savoir-faire et du territoire mais vous
savez combien dans les négociation de
traités de libre échange avec des
partenaires l'europe a du mal à faire
passer cette idée dao p2 de protection
de la belle et c'est donc si on vient à
ajouter en plus unis j'ai en ce qui
concerne les produits manufacturés
ça peut paraître comme du but la
protection clairement oui mais c'est la
protection du consommateur parce que
c'est une garantie de l'information du
consommateur quand vous achetez votre
jambon de bayonne vous êtes content de
savoir qu'il a été préparé et à dans le
secteur de bayonne idem pour le jambon
de parme et pourtant ça va pas se
percuter quand vous avez comme est
d'accord qu'à bruxelles il ya même plus
discussions sur ce sujet non c'est clair
ils ont décidé de protéger les artisans
dans toute l'europe exactement france
pionnière quel autre pays avancent aussi
la tue les italiens peuvent faire les
italiens pas plus tard qu'il ya trois
semaines encore on était en discussion
au travers de cette association globale
sur le territoire français la fia que je
citais tout à l'heure on était en
discussions avec les professionnels du
marbre de carrare donc vous voyez c'est
quelque chose de très divers si fier ce
qui est important vraiment c'est de
reconnaître on a un système qui s'appuie
beaucoup sur les grandes industries les
grandes entreprises voient beaucoup de
balles assez important que l'union
européenne qui peut paraître un
mastodonte pour certains eh ben c'est
important que l'union européenne
s'occupe aussi des petits si je puis
dire et des artisans qui crée de la
dynamique dans les territoires de
l'emploi et aussi permettre de
pérenniser certain savoir faire je
reviens juste deux petites secondes sur
les savoir faire mais vous savez suite
au drame de la delà de la cathédrale de
notre dame de paris on s'est rendu
compte qu'on avait perdu sa voix un
certain nombre de savoir faire donc
c'est bien la preuve qu'il est important
de protéger ses savoir-faire la dernière
qui sont qui contrôlent fait le plus vos
produits alors concernant nos produits
pour en propre ils sont assez peu
contrefaits c'est plus des le produit
qui pleurent force laine de limoges vous
allez pouvoir trouver sur internet c'est
ça c'est un gros problème c'est vraiment
le marché sur internet vous allez
pouvoir juger de la porcelaine de
limoges et donc qui vient de chine
merci tout va mieux merci à vous vos
réponses l'entretien de l'intelligence
économique est terminée mais évidemment
vous pouvez retrouver cette émission sur
france 24 points comme sur nos réseaux
sociaux et sur nos podcasts au revoir
[Musique]